la semaine sociale à venir s'annoncent
délicates pour le gouvernement c'est
toujours l'épreuve de force dans le
conflit des infirmières invraisemblable
depuis près de 30 ans aux etats-unis une
usine de traitement nucléaire contaminé
l'atmosphère tout ce qui devait savoir
savez il était au courant et me disait
rien un document exclusif antenne de
l'astronaute français patrick baudry
visite le centre d'entraînement des
cosmonautes chinois des installations
rustique mais efficace
la chine pourrait doubler l'europe pour
le lancement d'un premier vol spatial
habité
madame monsieur bonsoir un point
d'histoire avant d'entrer dans le vif de
l'actualité ce dimanche dans l'union
soviétique de gorbatchev qui jour après
jour déboulonne tous les mythes de
l'histoire officielle du socialisme
voilà une affaire qui sape à la base la
mythologie du travailleur communiste la
presse de moscou remette en cause
aujourd'hui le stakhanovisme la forme la
plus parfaite de la rentabilité et de
l'efficacité
son nom commun est à l'origine un nom
propre stakhanov un mineur qui dans une
nuit de l'année 1935 avait battu tous
les records de production de charbon un
modèle dont on dit aujourd'hui qui
n'était en fait qu'un tricheur
cette nuit-là stakhanov n'était pas seul
il s'était fait aider de deux autres
camarades
philippe bluff un nom va donc
disparaître de notre vocabulaire
jusque là on pouvait dire stakhanov pour
vous re de travail c'est fini ce mineur
soviétique de 31 ans qui réussit une
nuit de 1935 en extrayant 277 tonnes de
charbon un record extravagant n'est plus
aujourd'hui qu'une idole davis et alexei
stakhanov n'était pas seul il avait deux
aides
les historiens se méfier les soviétiques
douter la presse de gorbatchev taille
publiquement dans le mythe à l'époque
joseph staline fille de ce pseudo
exploit une médaille pour les méritants
et une méthode d'organisation de travail
le toujours plus il fallait motiver
impressionné le reste du monde et donner
l'exemple aux pays amis
qu'importe si des ouvriers - esclaves du
marteau piqueur assassinés à l'époque
plusieurs stakhanoviste stakhanoviste
mythe bidon c'est une nouvelle
illustration de l'image d'elle-même
qu'exporte l'union soviétique
n'at-on pas vu il ya peu la première
dame du kremlin prendre l'air du temps
chez saint laurent
n'at-on pas entendu il y à peu un
industriel dénoncée la tribune de la
conférence du parti à moscou la tendance
soviétique qui veut qu'il y ait des
clous quand il n'ya pas de marteau ou
encore cet écrivain star de la glace
note nous dire de staline qu'il était
moral il s'est dit et hypocrite en
vitrine
l'union soviétique est donc un produit
de plus en plus attrayant mais il y à
une contre publicité
selon les renseignements occidentaux ce
gigantesque effort de propagande se
double pour les espions soviétiques d'un
travail plus que jamais acharnée
après l'histoire l'actualité la france
est à la veille d'une semaine sociale
troublée avec les différentes journées
d'action organisée par le syndicat cgt
mardi mercredi et la grève générale de
la fonction publique prévu par les
autres syndicats jeudi 20 octobre mais
le premier conflit qui domine est celui
des infirmiers et infirmières il se
poursuit et visiblement le gouvernement
et la coordination des infirmières ne se
comprennent pas ou très mal
le premier ministre monsieur rocard
déclare est aujourd'hui dans une
interview au journal du dimanche
les infirmières n'ont sûrement pas
examiner à fond les propositions
d'augmentation qui leur ont été faites
et il ajoutait leur nom et sans doute un
refus du à l'énervement
réponse ce soir d'une des responsables
de la coordination interrogé par thierry
calmont il semblerait que monsieur
rocard nous considèrons mis en pris une
décision d'énervement et face au rejet
des propositions de monsieur et 20 je
crois que nous avons toujours trouvé
notre sens aigu des responsabilités
il est vraiment dommage que monsieur
rocard nous prennent comme ça un petit
peu à la légère les malades depuis le
début de la grève ont toujours été
soigné les infirmières se sont toujours
organisés ils ont toujours été
responsable des actes quelle honte
quelle on auprès des malades
comment est ce que vous pouvez à
l'espérer avoir quelque chose dans une
négociation alors que au départ vous
fixé tout de suite 2000 francs et vous
ne discutait pas là dessus mais c'est
pas vrai je crois que les infirmières de
base jeudi il n'y a pas besoin d'être
énarque pour comprendre je veux dire le
sens des propositions qui ont été faites
par monsieur yves 1 ce que nous
réclamons nous c'est un statut saint
statut c'est le droit et la
reconnaissance de nos compétences
1 il est évident que les infirmières de
base travail du jour et nuit dans les
hôpitaux qu'elle prenne en charge la vie
et la santé des malades il monsieur
rocard ne peut pas s'adresser à nous on
sait terne et comment est ce que vous
allez pouvoir arrêter un jour ça lui
rêve
apparemment drone est parti dans une
impasse non je crois que notre propos
aujourd'hui ce soir c'est nous nous
adressons solennellement
à monsieur rocard et nous lui demandons
enfin de pouvoir véritablement installée
instaurer un dialogue entre lui et nous
la coordination infirmières que nous
souhaitons c'est entre et entamer des
négociations ouvrir de riz de véritables
négociations et ceci dans la clarté et
pas dans des fonds de couloir comme cela
s'est si fait jusqu'à présent
et du côté du gouvernement on pense que
la difficulté de négociation dans le
conflit des infirmières s'explique en
partie par la présence de cette
coordination qui prend en charge les
revendications des salariés en marge des
syndicats officiels
ces coordinations qui sont une
expression plus ou moins directe des
salariés sont une nouveauté dans le
paysage social français depuis
souvenez vous la très dure grève des
cheminots en décembre 1986 face à l es
bien les pouvoirs publics et les chefs
d'entreprise ont beaucoup de mal à
trouver un terrain de compromis beaucoup
plus en tout cas qu'avec les syndicats
traditionnels véronique auger cheminots
ou infirmières l'émergence des
coordinations a toujours la même origine
la faiblesse des syndicats faible
audience chez les infirmières seulement
5 % d'entre elles sont syndiqués faible
crédibilité à la sncf les agents de
conduite par exemple sont syndiqués à
60%
mais ils croient de moins en moins à
l'efficacité syndicale les syndicats ne
s'entendent plus entre eux c'est à qui
annoncera un jour de grève le 1er la cgt
agit toujours seul et les mouvements
lancée par les organisations ne sont
plus suivis impression générale les
confédérations sont politisées leur
décision non plus qu'un lointain rapport
avec les véritables soucis des salariés
et pourtant les syndicats sont le
passage obligé dans toutes les
négociations avec le patronat et le
gouvernement
la première manifestation qu'on peut
constater à travers ça fait
effectivement là quelque chose d'une
carence syndicale du côté de la capacité
à énoncer la revendication effective de
ces acteurs qui sont contraintes de
faire eux même chez les infirmières
comme à la sncf le conflit a démarré sur
une pétition énorme mais là où les deux
mouvements diffère c'est dans la sortie
de la grève
et l'on retrouve une fois encore
l'influencé des syndicats ils sont
inexistants chez les infirmiers
elles sont jusqu'au boutiste tant
qu'elles n'auront pas satisfaction
entièrement elles n'arrêteront pas la
grève inconvénient en sortir forcé à
l'usure faute de combattants chez les
cheminots
les syndicats ont progressivement
récupérer le mouvement comme d'habitude
ils ont su l'arrêter à temps mais depuis
ils n'assurent toujours pas le suivi
précis des revendications de la base
dans les deux cas chacun se sentira pige
dans ce conflit des infirmières et des
infirmiers dernière prise de position ce
soir d'un membre du gouvernement au club
de la presse d'europe 1 le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur
pierre bérégovoy d'éclat il faut savoir
arrêter une grève et négocier ce qui a
été obtenu n'est pas négligeable
monsieur bérigaud fois ce n'est pas un
promouvoir c'est une mesure de justice
qui était proposé à l'intention des
infirmières il s'agit d'une part
d'améliorer leur rémunération leur
salaire d'autre part d'améliorer leurs
conditions de travail et de leur offrir
des perspectives de carrière le problème
est ancien aussi longtemps que nous
avons été alertés sur le site sur une
infirmière
tant et si bien qu'on avait fait voter
une loi à la fin de 1985 qui portait
réforme de leur statut
on n'a rien fait pendant ces dix ans
plusieurs années on a eu tort ce que
j'ai l'intention de demander aux
infirmières qui m'écoutent aux
surveillants aux aides soignantes car
tous ces personnels sont concernés c'est
de mesurer l'importance de l'effort qui
fait non pas par le gouvernement mais
par la nation c'est la sécurité sociale
autrement dit tous les français qui vont
contribuer qui vont contribuer à cette
amélioration
et j'ai l'intention de le redire très
car je crois qu'ils savent que je les
comprends et depuis longtemps
j'ai l'intention de rire il faut savoir
est une grève et continuer la discussion
sur les matières on peut encore avancer
car les propositions sont perfectibles
ces revendications salariales font le
sel tache d'huile dans la fonction
publique les syndicats d'enseignants
appellent également à la grève jeudi
prochain
et lorsqu'on sait que quelles que soient
les avantages de ce métier d'enseignant
eh bien il doit être
revaloriser financièrement pour susciter
de nouvelles vocations aux questions
urgentes d'ailleurs paradoxalement
pourtant dans les écoles normales ce qui
aujourd'hui se destine à la carrière de
professeur d'instituteurs plutôt ne
place pas forcément l'argent en tête de
leurs préoccupations primordiales pour
eux reste la vocation chantal kimmerlin
patrick reste les élèves instituteurs ne
sont plus ce qu'ils étaient dans cette
école normale des batignolles à paris
comme dans tous les départements de
france on a recruté cette année des
candidats entre 20 et 49 ans jeune
universitaire diplômé ex professionnels
du privé ou du public chômeurs en
reconversion mère de famille démons tous
ont signé pour au moins dix ans quand on
est jeune on n'a pas toujours conscience
de ce que l'on ce dont on est capable de
faire et je crois qu'il est plus
intéressant enfin j'estime plus
intéressant pour moi de me mettre au
service des enfants que de me mettre au
service de la publicité
autant de parents d'élèves aussi j'ai vu
des problèmes d'enfants à la référence
6e et je pense qu'une bonne partie de la
responsabilité vient de l'école primaire
ou de ce qui se passe à l'école primaire
huit des dix futurs mobiles it et
professionnels plus grande vocation
amont des enfants réalité du chômage
quelle que soit leur motivation les
candidats instituteur change et sont
aussi plus adulte qui hier moyenne d'âge
30 ans contre 20 ans autrefois je crois
surtout qu'il apporte un autre regard
sur l'école il me semble que lorsqu'on
recrutait des tout jeunes niveau brevet
puis niveau baccalauréat on recrutait
des jeunes qui voulaient devenir
instituteur mais si vous voulez qu'ils
n'avaient pas idée de la responsabilité
qu'un adulte instituteur peut avoir dans
notre société
les gens qui viennent de milieux
professionnels où ils ont exercé des
responsabilités savent très bien que
ils n'auront pas seulement à être
enseignants les enfants les enfants
évoluent la situe la société évolue donc
on a obligé d'évoluer également voulu
savoir quelle place dans la société en
tant qu'institutrice est reconnu comme
institutrice
qu'ils soient jeunes ou plus âgés ils
ont tous un point commun volontaires
pour l'enseignement
il s'y donne avec passion en france
encore 17 du président du conseil
régional rhône alpes
monsieur charles béraudier udf victime
d'une crise cardiaque à l'âge de 68 ans
sa succession à la tête du conseil
régional rhône alpes s'annonce difficile
il ne disposait en effet que d'une seule
voix d'avancé sur le ministre centriste
michel durafour rallié au gouvernement
de monsieur michel rocard à l'étranger
en algérie une semaine après la fin des
émeutes le gouvernement a décidé de
relâcher plusieurs centaines de jeunes
qui avaient été appréhendés dans les
manifestations de la semaine dernière
d'autres prises en flagrant délit ont
été jugés aujourd'hui en série alger
pour apaiser la colère et accélérer un
retour à la vie normale
le pouvoir a également décidé
d'augmenter le tonnage des importations
de denrées essentielles des produits qui
manquent cruellement à certains et pas à
d'autres
car en algérie aujourd'hui deux sociétés
cohabitent sans se rencontrer
d'un côté les privilégiés du régime de
l'autre la majorité des déshérités
bruno le dreff jean corde
rillettes el fath jardin d'à victoire en
france est construite il ya trois ans
est la vitrine de la politique
d'ouverture du président chadli vérité
des prix produisent occidentaux rigueur
musulmane 90 alimente oublier trois
étages de luxueuses boutiques quatre
restaurants chics dont pas un oriental
une boîte de nuit fameuse le triangle ou
la bouteille de whisky coûte 2500 dinars
le smig par comparaison est à 1200
dinars un centre commercial réservé à
quelques privilégiés
l'immense majorité de la population
algéroise vite ailleurs dans d'autres
conditions
dans un autre monde mais les habitants
plus particulièrement les jeunes de
quartiers déshérités comme celui ci ne
peuvent évidemment pas s'offrir les
plaisirs du jardin de la victoire
pendant que les jeunes bourgeois
s'éclate dans les voiles de nuit dure
hiatale fait ici les enfants survivent
en vendant des cigarettes de contrebande
c'est le monde des 3d comme dette
démographie dépendance et c'est ici en
grande partie qu'il faut chercher les
émeutiers
mais il fuit la caméra les privilégiés
se retrouve à l'université pourtant dans
l'algérie d'aujourd'hui les diplômes ne
sont plus synonymes d'emplois alors on
avoue comprendre les émeutiers
le manifestant comme les quatre hip hop
ils ont plu au lieu de leur tête une
tête brûlée voyez tandis que un étudiant
il réfléchit peut-être deux fois ou
trois fois avant avant de se lancer
je veux travailler avec bonne raison de
risque éventuellement leur peau
je pense que oui
si bon que je pense plus
ces raisons c'est quoi la démocratie à
parole au peuple
plus de liberté depuis quelques jours à
jay a retrouvé son calme mais dans de
nombreuses familles on pleure un mort un
blessé ou on s'inquiète pour un disparu
le leader palestinien yasser arafat
censuré par la télévision israélienne y
figurer dans une séquence télévisée d'un
parti politique marginal rassemblant des
juifs et les arabes et qui participe
actuellement à la campagne électorale en
israël dans cette interview réalisée en
france il ya quelques semaines il
reconnaissait implicitement l'état
d'israël la commission supérieure
chargée de superviser la campagne
électorale a décidé donc de censurer
cette séquence le parlement européen lui
qui avait reçu dans un certain tumulte
yasser arafat à strasbourg il ya
quelques semaines n'aura pas de a décidé
que il ne recevrait pas pour l'instant
officiellement le leader palestinien la
communauté européenne en tant qu'entité
officielle n'est donc pas prête à
recevoir le leader palestinien
à peine croyable cette information venue
des états unis dans l'état de l'ohio une
usine de traitement nucléaire contaminé
l'atmosphère depuis près de trente ans
maintenant et tout ce qui devait être au
courant l'été sans pour autant le dire
jagland cette usine qui fabrique le
combustible pour les bombardiers les
sous marins nucléaires du pentagone est
dangereuse
plus grave encore les autorités savaient
que le fonctionnement de lusine
entraîner des émissions d'uranium et de
substances radioactives
à l'extérieur les fuites contamine tout
l'atmosphère l'eau et les habitants de
la région depuis environ 30 ans au cours
d'une audition au congrès à la suite de
rapports alarmants
les témoignages sont accablants la
commission a rendu son arrêt le cancer
du foie de mon père a bien été provoquée
par la radioactivité présente sur le
site
ce qui est sûr c'est que le gouvernement
a sciemment ou inconsciemment mise en
danger la vie de ses citoyens et que ces
citoyens n'ont aucun recours
parler de tout le monde accuse le
problème c'est que l'on fait tout pour
la bande
ensuite les rentrées fiscales et en
dernier la sécurité le gouvernement
américain avoue avec un cynisme
incroyable qu'il savait le département
de l'énergie reconnaît son incapacité au
début la technologie nécessaire pour
empêcher les fuites n'existait pas
ensuite c'est l'argent
les fonds qu'ils n'étaient pas
disponibles pour les travaux et pourtant
ils ont continué tremblement de terre en
grèce dans les îles de la mer ionienne 6
degrés sur l'échelle de richter des
dégâts importants dans la région
touristique de patras une certaine
panique dans la population
mais on ne dénombre pour l'instant que
quelques blessés ce tremblement de terre
avait été annoncée pour le mois de
septembre par le spécialiste français
haroun tazieff
une prévision qui à l'époque avait été
contesté par les spécialistes grecque
plusieurs autres secousses sismiques ont
été enregistrés aujourd'hui ce dimanche
dans l'archipel des açores
et puis un paquebot soviétique au large
de l'île de malte en feu la nuit
dernière 300 personnes à bord en
majorité des français qui ont été
heureusement débarquer saine et sauve
c'est ce qu'a indiqué ce soir
l'ambassade soviétique dans l'île de
malte il y a trois mois souvenez-vous en
mer du nord une plate forme pétrolière
piper alpha c'était son nom sombre est à
la suite d'un incendie faisant 167
victime aujourd'hui est bien la
plateforme a été remonté à la surface
claude crespin
cette grue géante a fini par arracher
hier les quartiers d'habitation de piper
alpha
ce module qui est en fait un immeuble de
quatre étages gisait depuis trois mois
et 9 jours par 150 mètres de fond et
c'est à l'intérieur que sont mortes la
plupart des victimes de la plus grande
catastrophe de l'industrie pétrolière
offshore
le bilan était de 167 morts
mais rien que dans cette immense
cercueil sans doute personnes sont
restées prisonnières et leurs corps
n'ont pas été retrouvés
un mois de préparation 400 techniciens
pour parvenir à ce premier résultat
maintenant une barge va transporter
cette carcasse au large de l'ecosse pour
permettre à la police d'identifier les
victimes les familles n'auront pas à
participer à cette douloureuse opération
la police a choisi un processus
scientifique d'identification
effondrement d'un pont de la ligne a du
rer ce matin de bonne heure à nanterre
dans la banlieue parisienne tablier du
pont qui était en réparation s'est
écroulé d'après la ratp la sécurité des
voyageurs n'avaient jamais été
compromise puisque le trafic avait été
interrompu pour ces travaux tout devrait
être redevenue normale demain
aujourd'hui 16 octobre 10e anniversaire
de l'arrivée à la tête de l'église
catholique du pape jean paul ii dix
années qui sont déjà entrées dans
l'histoire de ce pape pèlerin sillonnant
le monde progressistes et conservateurs
à la fois
miraculé de la haine marcel trillât
saura-t-on jamais ce qu'ils se sont dit
dans le secret de cette cellule de
prison où jean paul ii rendez visite à
allier axa l'homme qui avait voulu le
tuer
rien d'autre peut-être que les mots du
pardon est ce dur en pâtir mais nul
n'oubliera l'image de ce pape fauché
dans son élan le 13 mai 1981
sur la place saint pierre de rome et qui
rend partira à peine quelques mois plus
tard à l'assaut du monde 1 tapez dans
l'élection déjà le 16 octobre 1978 avait
provoqué la stupeur
pour la première fois depuis plus de
quatre cent cinquante ans ce n'était pas
un italien qui se profilait derrière le
nuage de fumée blanche du conclave
mais karol wojtyla cardinal de cracovie
un pape venu de l'est du jean paul
besset impact médiatique extraordinaire
dès les premiers jours on a pu se
rencontrent
à peine élu à la loggia la démesure
saint-pierre s'adresser à la foule avec
son achat après comme le mien si vous
vouler
qui
si je me trompe pour les gemmois on
s'était un éclat de rire est le média de
masse et déjà été conquis à peine
intronisé jean paul ii bouscule sans
pitié les ancestrales tradition sur
lesquels d'onctueux monsignore veiller
jalousement jusqu'ici la cdja geste à
tort en rien la chaise à porteurs qui
donnait le mal de mer à ses
prédécesseurs et mise au rancart sans
ménagement le nouveau pape ne
s'embarrasse pas de simagrées qu'ils
cherchent le contact direct avec le
peuple de dieu 40 expédition aux quatre
coins du monde 74 pays visités six cent
mille kilomètres parcourus c'est comme
si jean paul ii avait fait en dix ans
quinze fois le tour de la terre des
voyages parfois controversés comme au
chili de pinochet ou de l'autriche de
valdaï des voyages souvent porteurs
d'espoir en afrique en amérique latine -
en pologne pour des foules réconforté
par un message de solidarité
opposé à toutes les oppressions à l'est
comme à l'ouest avec ce pape
missionnaire l'église catholique affirme
aux yeux du monde son identité sans état
d'âme continuateurs loyal du concile
vatican ii
jean paul ii rassemble à assise en
octobre 1986
toutes les grandes religions du monde
pour une prière oecuménique
les conservateurs fanatisés par
monseigneur lefebvre ne le lui pardonne
pas et c'est le schisme en juin dernier
la comptine saint yves et d'autres
catholiques n'hésite pas de leur côté a
jugé franchement rétrograde ses propos
sur la sexualité ou ses arguments pour
justifier son opposition irrémédiable à
l'accès des femmes à la prêtrise le
christ affirme été récemment n'a choisi
que des hommes condisciples comme si le
plus moderne des papes oublier parfois
que le monde en 2000 ans avait quelque
peu changé évita les affaires du ciel
encore mais pas sur naturelle celle là
un nouveau venu dans la course à
l'espace la chine qui après les états
unis et l'union soviétique pourrait bien
doubler l'europe pour le lancement d'un
vol habité en exclusivité pour antenne 2
ce soit et bien l'astronaute français
patrick baudry a visité le centre
d'entraînement des futurs cosmonautes
chinois rustique vous allez le voir mais
efficace patrick estève
7 millions de vélos 10 millions
d'habitants et depuis quelques mois 12
cosmonautes à l'entraînement
actuellement la chine s'éveille à la
haute technologie à une vitesse qui
surprend l'occident récemment la société
spatiale de la grande muraille a signé
des accords avec des compagnies privées
américaines pour procéder au lancement
de leurs satellites commerciaux et déjà
la chine attaque fermement la technique
du vol spatial habité
patrick baudry a pu il y a quelques
jours rencontrer les responsables de
l'entraînement de ses futurs cosmonautes
mieux
ceux ci lui ont fait visiter dans la
banlieue de beijing le centre ultra
secret de l'institut médico technique de
l'espace et ne vous laissez pas abuser
par le côté un peu rustique et un peu
foire du trône que peut avoir cette
balance elle patrick baudry lui même en
est sorti tout palau jugeant du même
coup les sica 6 pts et redoutable du
système pour habituer les cosmonautes au
mal de l'espace
ici dans cet autre atelier cinq
candidats au voyage cosmique sont
enfermés durant vingt-neuf jours à
l'intérieur d'un caisson pressurisée
dont le frère jumeau tournera peut-être
bientôt au tour de la terre sur ce siège
que les techniciens les chuter
brutalement en créant une accélération
formidable les douze cosmonautes chinois
s'entraîne à tour de rôle à subir
l'épreuve de l'atterrissage de leur
capsule
enfin pour tester l'equilibre de chaque
individu et voir comment il réussit à
s'orienter dans l'espace voici le
fauteuil tournant le cobaye humain se
trouve placé en rotation suivante
plusieurs axes et alors là j'allais dire
bonjour le mal de mer on leur équipement
scientifiquement tout à fait excellent
même si les apparences prête
de temps en temps un sourire pour un
européen disons pour des pros des gens
qui comme nous sommes très attachés aux
et aux apparences de la technologie pour
le professeur andrew go le chef de
centre qui le dit avec le sourire
pas de doute possible les chinois seront
capables de voyager dans l'espace avant
l'an 2000 c'est à dire peut-être avant
même les européens
une belle réussite pour un pays qui a
démarré sa propre conquête de l'espace
en copiant les vieilles fusées
soviétiques après l'étonnement la
fascination et l'émotion même la plus
grande chanteuse du monde arabe
fayrouz chrétienne libanaise d'origine
donne est aujourd'hui un concert unique
au palais des sports de bercy à paris
en europe nous n'imaginons pas ou mal la
ferveur qui entoure cette vedette plus
qu'une idole elle est le symbole de la
nation rap comme le fut autrefois
d'ailleurs l'égyptienne oum kalsoum jean
marbre frêle silhouette visage grave
presque austère et une voix rauque
autant presque fait les symboles de son
pays natal déchiré le liban tel est fair
use la turquoise en arabe bercy ou
beirut mêmes frémissements même
admiration même recueillement plus
grande de championnat alors
les sortes d hanovre
merci
les dames hygiène de cours est donc bien
d'être loin justement pour ses dépens du
liban étaient là c'est une pour moi une
des plus grandes chanteuses au monde
oui absolument ambitieux il faisait donc
on fait rousset ou calcul c'est une
idole du monde arabe
il est très connu puis pour nous disons
que ça remplace un peu en dessous c'est
une femme qui est folle et d'années
qu'elle exprime ses
et ces idées en chansons nous venons de
marseille pour voir firouz parce que si
notre idole l'élément beaucoup et puis
moi je suis français mais ma mère et
origines libanaises et il ya 60 ans
qu'elle est en france et les chansons de
fairouz lui rappelle son liban natal
comment expliquez-vous le mythe que vous
représentez dans tout le moyen-orient
aïda sow elle la neige laisse jouer à
dresser avec nous à moi j'ai chanté
simplement et c'est eux qui m'ont écouté
et qui m'ont nommé inscrivait la manade
mes chansons aussi que font un seul
répertoire c'est des chansons d'amour
l'amour de l'amour l'amour de la terre
l'amour de génétique ou l'amour de dieu
qui existent dans tous et nous chantent
leurs terres le port est l'homme dont
l'ambassadrice du liban auprès des
étoiles comme on l'a surnommé possède
cette extraordinaire mme charisme qui
électrise les foules littéralement
idolâtré à la renouveler la tradition et
apporte aujourd'hui un message de paix
dans tout le moyen-orient
plus prosaïque que pour terminer les
résultats du tiercé qui se courait
aujourd'hui à longchamp pour gagner il
fallait jouer le 15 le 4 et le 5 et pour
ce qui concerne le quarté mais il
fallait ajouter le dise pour gagner un
petit peu plus de 40 mille francs
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après il ya les prévisions météo
avec josé blanc lapierre et des
nouvelles du séisme en grèce dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure et puis en
fin de programme vous retrouverez tout à
l'heure hervé claude les rendez vous de
demain c'est 6h45 télématin avec les
premières informations et puis demain
soir à 20h vous retrouverez ici même
avec christine ockrent je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bien sûr et je vous dis à samedi
prochain bonne semaine
bon